[Music]
joseph calling from savannah georgia to
kick off this hour what's up joseph
uh good afternoon gentlemen um
just uh where to call and uh ask for
some words of encouragement and um
help me as a to stay off losing
motivation i'm on uh baby step
number six uh currently working two jobs
and i've been praying for god to help me
with
discernment to see if
i should continue working the two jobs
because the anxiety is just
it's getting to be a lot and
even though sending that big chunk to
the mortgage company every month feels
good
uh so you are debt-free except your
house
correct you're putting 15 of your income
into retirement
correct why are you working two jobs
uh because when i started this uh baby
step seven was always the goal um yeah
but we didn't teach you to stay gazelle
intense
after four we said move from intense to
intentional
you go from sprint to marathon when you
go into four five and six
so how many hours a week are you working
uh it's two full-time jobs
okay what do you make at your main job
um i'm making 80.
and what do you make of the second job
60. and what do you owe on your house
uh 240. are you married
no
you have kids
yes
you have custody of the kids
uh 50
and uh i'm covering tuition
what does a second job consist of
uh business analysts
so both both work both jobs are remote
so you're never off cut the second job
in half or by 75 percent or quit it
completely today
you don't need that 60k
dave and i both know a bunch of
millionaires who crossed that finish
line and they looked around and had
nothing that's why we teach it the way
we do yeah
uh the you know you've
you know you've taken gazelle intensity
and put it over into those last several
baby steps and it's not sustainable yeah
the human body the human spirit you're
you're running out of gas that's why
you're calling because you you're
gasping for air and i don't blame you
you're listen you're not afraid of hard
work and you're actually not a
workaholic you're just so goal driven
and focus driven that you've run you've
run yourself out of your own shoes
when was your divorce
uh 2018.
you still running
yes
yeah
gotta stop
because that shadow's chasing you and
chasing you and chasing you and as the
sun moves that shadow gets faster and
longer it's going to catch you there's
something that is a little bit
uh it feels like you're afraid if you
sit still you won't like what you hear
or c
am i wrong
um i think
being alone these last couple years
god has been teaching me to
listen to myself so
i've appreciated being alone and taking
the time to reflect um
i think
i don't know when you had that time
[Laughter]
listen listen
there is none zero there is no long-term
wellness there's no long-term
long-term healing there's no long-term
life with joy in it that is done in
isolation
and that it's done with this many hours
right in the job
two full-time jobs is it's not
sustainable you can do it for two or
three years and you have
all right because you busted through the
first several baby steps and that's fine
i don't i'm not afraid of hard work i'm
not afraid of telling people to go work
hard but um you know if i the way i
answer questions here joseph is i woke
up in your shoes i'm three years this
out of a divorce i got 50
of my time with my babies and uh all i
got left to do is knock out the mortgage
i'm currently putting 15 of my income
away i make 80. i could easily take that
60 dollar back to 20 and i'd have so
much free time i wouldn't know what to
do with it and that's what i would do
and then you you just kind of i want you
take a deep breath and it feels like
cold mountain air in the morning coming
into your lungs that's called peace and
just feel it
and that's what i would want for you
that's what i would want to be if i were
you
um
and so
i i kind of did something similar and
i'm not accusing you of this uh but but
uh when we went through bankruptcy
i worked like an absolute maniac the
other side of that because i was so
scared
and i didn't i didn't want to stop i
didn't want to i i didn't want to dial
it back and um
uh and it wasn't it wasn't a workaholism
it wasn't in that sense but but it was
just a running like john was saying and
so if i were in your shoes i'd dial it
back
yeah i think there's no question and i
want when you two dial it back brother i
want you to
make a commitment to yourself i'm gonna
go walk i'm gonna go to the gym a few
times a week
and i'm gonna get a group of guys and
i'm gonna invite them over the house and
we're gonna i don't know what you're
into we're gonna watch fights we're
gonna watch don't watch golf on tv god
help you but we're gonna get a group of
guys over together and we're gonna watch
something we're gonna do something
together and i'm gonna begin to build
back relationships in my life you had
two years of being in complete and total
isolation that anxiety alarm that you're
feeling is ringing off the wall because
your body is saying hey we're not we're
not we're not safe you called us because
you wanted us to tell you what you
already knew that's right
that happens a lot around here